he's daryl morey he's the Rockets GM
Carmelo Anthony is signed sealed finally
delivered how's morale in Houston there
Daryl very good yeah no five-year
five-year pass had terminal Anthony's
and someone we've been interested in a
long time wait so when did it start how
close did you get him to landing Carmelo
before this well we actually actually
more than five years I think about it we
were trying to trade for him when his in
Denver before he went to New York then
we met with him in free agency I believe
that was maybe three four years ago now
and then last year potential trade with
the Knicks so yeah it's been it's been a
while we we generally target guys we
think will be good for our system and
and usually don't give up
well explain that though what how do you
plug-and-play mellow in the system now
considering his age and his style yeah I
mean generally what we try to do and you
see our history here is we try to get
guys who are multi-talented to have the
ability to score in different ways and
and then with coach D'Antoni we feel
like he's able to get the most out of
players if you look at his history he's
been able to get the most out of pretty
much everyone I know they they had a bit
of a rocky time and in New York but a
lot of a lot of coaches the philosophies
of evolved since he came here I think
even he would say he's taken what he's
done and done one more revision down
here and really really put the floor you
know the accelerator to the floor
essentially in terms of style of play
and we think Carmelo especially at the
fore especially with his ability to
shoot is a great fit for us
felt like the topic when when he signed
when he finally signed was would he be a
starter come off the bench was that ever
discussed prior to him signing of what
his role would be with the Rockets
yeah we talked about everything we
talked about you know how how we might
start games how we might finish games
which i think is actually as you know
you've been a longtime sports watcher
longer than me that finishing games you
can argue is even more important than we
basically told him what we told Chris
Paul a year ago which is look we're
gonna figure this out we're gonna figure
out the combinations that work that
could mean any number of roles for
anybody you know guys who had been
career started like Eric Gordon have
come off the bench PJ Tucker last year
started off the bench ended up starting
so finishing games was actually all over
the map you know guys like Trevor Clint
capela even Chris and James sometimes
didn't always necessarily finished if
the team was rolling so I think Mike
just said look we got a talented team
all of us are trying to prove something
work we really only focused on one thing
at this point we got a better bunch of
veteran guys trying to win a ring and
you know the thing that worked last
year's everyone was willing to do
whatever coach thought was best and and
that's what got us to 65 wins and you
know a hamstring away I think of winning
it last year how much are you relying on
analytics now I mean a lot I mean we're
I mean that that's an area we try to
differentiate ourselves and hopefully we
continue to do that I think you know
once you have your team know I think
obviously it's a lot of that is done in
the acquisition side and that was built
up over the years but you know coach
will even talk about it I mean even we
were talking with Carmelo when we're
looking at what combinations work
because we have a very deep talented
squad you know he's he's obviously using
his intuition and his 30-plus almost 40
years of coaching but he's also using
information that he's provided to help
him make decisions and I think you know
he you know Mike's really been pulling
all the all the right strings all the
right strings so far sterile Maury the
Rockets GM joining us Dan Patrick show
everything is sick a cyclical it feels
like Darrell so I feel like one day
somebody's gonna go big and and maybe
it's after the Golden State era but
somebody's gonna go hey we're gonna make
you match up
against us I know with the importance of
the three but can you see where somebody
just goes counterintuitive to this 100%
agree that in fact we had an extremely
effective lineup that we use when we had
Dwight and Clint you know when he was
younger and just up and coming when we
played them together we just beat the
hell out of people actually and the
rebounding is actually still pretty
underrated if you can create a
rebounding edge by being bigger it's
actually extremely effective now you
gotta have guys I don't know us I don't
know if Dwight and Clinton would work
maybe to cleanse could work you got to
have guys who can be mobile and guard
the perimeter that are big hmm but if
you could create a big rebounding edge I
do think that's a counter and I do think
one thing I love about the NBA and I'm
glad you brought it up is there's no one
way to do this I mean there's obviously
been these different waves and rule
changes have affected it but it's a very
dynamic game that changes every year
what was your reaction when boogie
cousin signed with Golden State I was I
was really curious I mean I you know
Bobby is really good at his job and he
he likes to take smart Gamble's like I
do and so I understood the move but it's
gonna be interesting I mean they're
obviously you know coach Kerr is one of
the best too so it's a little scary who
they'll probably figure out how to make
it work but it's it's a little bit hard
on paper to figure out how to make it
work but you know we do that well and so
today so they're gonna be a tough out
again obviously you know they're
arguably the best best team in NBA
history I mean they're there they're on
their path to maybe be able to make that
argument when LeBron went to the Lakers
I guess no surprise but did we do we
factor the Lakers in as contenders in
the West oh man you can't it's hard to
count LeBron out I mean I think to be
fair to magic and Rob polenka it's a
little hard to put some together that
works right away in the first year I
know it took him one year in Miami
before before they got rolling and
and so I would expect I hope that you
know we're ahead of them and I would
expect on state to be ahead of them but
I would never count out a lebron james
team i mean he is the greatest ever in
my mind and and be very hard to very
hard to count him out
now you think LeBron is the best player
of all time are you using your analytics
to assess that yeah yeah we definitely
we explain that part of it I mean I
think you just look at his ability his
ability to you know generate wins and
championship probability over time and
and you basically break that down and
obviously you know you don't have to you
don't need all the numbers you can watch
as well and see that but but if you if
you basically isolate that and also look
at the career he's had you know frankly
I think it's at this point it's become a
bit of a big margin actually where he's
he's come out ahead I know that's a
little controversial I was also
surprised that the NBA sort of
acknowledged the James Harden if he
travels and and wasn't there a video
that was sent out you know to the other
teams just and maybe you can help me
with this kind of fill in the gray area
there but what what did the way say
about this and when they saw the videos
of you know teams were saying hey you're
letting Harden get getting away with the
travel yeah they they actually the
credit the league I mean they sent out a
video showing he wasn't it you know
frankly he's an extremely crafty player
that you know that's why it was MVP and
you know every year he's adding
something new to his game and did you
think you know rattling no Daryl just
just a little bit I don't actually I
mean now maybe it looks like a travel to
people and they maybe the rule needs to
be changed but I mean obviously they
have the rules for reason and if you if
you take the traveling rules and apply
them like James is not traveling on on
all his signature moves I mean I think
when Ginobili and others you know first
we're doing the earth that people
thought that was a travel and pretty
pretty quickly they realized there
wasn't
did you get an audience with LeBron at
all did you have a fair shake I mean he
has his own process and he makes his own
decisions and we all respect that so you
know I think you know he's been in a
league long enough he knew he knew our
situation and obviously made the the
choice you thought was best for him and
so that we we have nothing but respect
for that if your life was in the balance
and you had to have hardened shooter
three
Steph Curry or klay Thompson who's taken
the three stationery top of the key I'm
gonna give you I'll give you a hardened
sweet spot if hardens heavily guarded
and he's and he's taking one drivel and
doing a step back I'll take James Harden
who shot that shot at almost 50 percent
last year and I think I think the career
high on that shot and NBA history prior
to that was like 32 percent so I'll take
James on that's know I'm talking about
stationary nobody's garden anybody
Darryl your life hang you're gonna get a
pay raise if whoever you pick if they
make the shot you get a contract
extension you can have hardened clay or
staff and their feet are set another
thing I think Eric Gordon the of the the
three-point challenge contest winner you
think Eric Gordon is the best standing
3-point shooter in the NBA as long as
you take your guy you can't go wrong
it's you're gonna make news if you say
you know what if my life's on the line
I'm taking Steph Curry 80 percent if
they're wide open and congrats and
should be fun this upcoming season we
appreciate your time Darryl hey that's a
daryl morey the Rockets DM for more Dan
Patrick show
the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]